well from leeds we're joined by tracy
braven the mayor of west yorkshire uh
good afternoon to you thanks very much
indeed for joining us in what is an
incredibly busy day for everyone up and
down
the country can you tell us the picture
there and how are people responding to
it in west yorkshire
well hello sima and uh it is disruptive
we have seen that leeds station is
relatively empty
but people are still moving about our
region our park and rides are busier
than they have been on the bus network
of course but it's obviously a difficult
time for young people doing their exams
and also for workers to to get to their
place of work we're a region where we
don't have as many uh white-collar
workers who can potentially work from
home as other regions so it's really
important that we try and mitigate as
much as we can and make sure people can
still move around and you're actually in
the third week of a
bus service disruption as well aren't
you and i know that you were saying that
you've spoken to both sides trying to
get to a positive conclusion for the
people of west yorkshire what do you
make of this rail strike
do you believe the rmt should have gone
ahead with this strike or should they
have struck a deal they have been
offered uh depends on which side you
speak to a two or three percent uh pay
increase
well we are in a cost of living crisis
and let's not forget the people who
works on the railways they they got us
through the pandemic making sure that
our emergency workers our key workers
could get around now i'm not going to
comment on the on the veracity of their
claims because i'm not in the room but
my understanding is they have been in
discussions for uh almost a year and
nobody wants to go on strike lightly
because let's not forget there's also
reduction in your money that's coming
into your pocket and when we talk about
people being affected obviously the the
people who work for the railways are
those people who are going to be
affected their families are going to be
affected as well nobody goes on strike
lightly but as you say in west yorkshire
we have a dispute with arriva and unite
and i am hoping that over the next day
or so we could get to some resolution to
make sure we can see the end of this
it's really important that working
people can say to government that um we
are seeing a real uh cut in our wages
due to inflation and my understanding is
that railway workers haven't had a pay
rise in over two to three years and it
is fair and just that they can make
their case uh mayor braven it sounds to
me like you support these strikes
well i support passengers
i am i am the voice of the passenger i
am a boss untrained passenger myself
what i what i support is the right to
strike that is the last resort for
people who want to see better paying
conditions but of course the disruption
is great uh as we've seen in wakefield
it's been really hard for that community
because we don't have a a fantastic rail
network in wakefield and and the five
towns
the community really rely on the buses
there are people paying 20 pounds a day
in taxes to get to work a hundred pounds
a week and it's been going on now into
the third week this cannot continue and
we have to come to some sort of question
then if you support the right to strike
the strikes are causing disruption for
the people you represent in west
yorkshire
and of course people right across the
country what is the solution if not a
pay rise and better working conditions
well that's absolutely absolutely the
solution is coming to a compromise where
people are paid properly for a day's
work and also that um we don't see those
cuts to numbers in in so-called
efficiencies and protecting people's
right to have a a safe and decent
environment to work in it is down to
those companies like ariva and also i
would suggest the governments to to get
involved in in in finding a solution